orlando really trying to buckle down and
play some ds did sucks get that block
sure on that one
[Applause]
there they are look right but look right
here smitty looks like a little horns
action though oh
he's watching right now horns the guy's
gonna go under a little squeeze action
and
it's jalen suggs knocking it down okay
coach mosley had a game against alabama
he was 16 for 19.
that's impressive
domingo
attacks and is good
you know the seat of the whole court
five on the shot clock sucks takes it
attacks and hits on the other side
see 3d you know let me off the hook step
to get to the final four 3d and then
beat us beat michigan state
i don't want to bring up old stuff
smitty are they going to go for two here
oh turnover kyle guy with the ball
eyes up drops it off
look at himself
[Applause]
kyle guy tried to drop it off jalen
sucks with a 360 spin still finds the
ball blocks it retains possession
paul anthony spinning turns the
basketball over
kaminga hits ahead gets it back
a little heavy attacks the rim and good
man this could be a preview for what you
will see during the regular season yeah
they have guys that could be starting
right now and they're suds again
[Applause]
uh-oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i played them during the regular season
they came to the palace three days oh
yeah
the next thing you know larry johnson
was too much
moody in transition finds kalinga with
the dock
let's watch it that's not going too fast
letting it run and gary payton by him
running head cold anthony stuck
seeing which guy and then kaminga
running down the lane that's beautiful
basketball letting that
yeah i could see it a little bit
[Applause]
loses anthony finds his teammate moody
under the rim
10 on the shot clock now
thugs with the steal six seconds left
attacking the rim all the way in
goaltending will be the call short but
cole anthony gets the rebound another
opportunity suggs with the fake pass
good block by camiga
yes we got some good basketball
he has 10 points six rebounds already
for jalen suggs
and another steal and will he hit this
jeff
his second steal for subs
everybody's playing his three shot
three-point ball
and he drives it and finishes with his
left
turnover oh kaminga
[Applause]
gary payton the second quickly
oh my goodness but could not convert
five on the shot clock
have to attack now jessop's got to score
it
turnover look at who it is
that's the second block by the rim today
oh okay i was gonna say look like it was
close